ادعى Max verstappen فوزه الخامس عشر
في موسم 2022 F1 وحمل
العلم المتقلب في سباق جائزة أبو ظبي الكبرى في
نوفمبر ،
لكن سيارته لم تكن هي الوحيدة التي
لفتت الانتباه من الحشود في نهاية هذا الأسبوع ، فقد ساعد
هذا الأسطول المكون من جميع السيارات ذاتية القيادة
المشجعين على الوصول وإلي.
مضمار السباق هذا هو مشروع التنقل الذكي الخاص بنا
، وهو يتكون من ثلاث حافلات
نقل سريع أوتوماتيكي
ست حافلات صغيرة أو روبو وثمانية
سيارات
أجرة روبو تختبر الشركة هذه الروبوتات المتحركة
وهي
الحراب وشركة الاستخبارات الجغرافية الخاصة في أبو ظبي
يطلق عليها سيارات الأجرة على الرغم مما يبدو
الخطأ المطبعي والعلامة التجارية ، وبينما
يتم تصميم المركبات وتصنيعها في
الخارج ، فإن البرنامج الذي يتم تشغيله
عليه هو محلي في أبو ظبي ، ومحكمتنا
عبارة عن منطقة جغرافية مكانية حيث نقوم ببناء
الخريطة نفسها ، فنحن نبني الخرائط ثلاثية الأبعاد
حتى تفهم السيارة نفسها
أين  إنها تتحرك
المركبات ، لذا وفقًا لأحدث مؤشر KPMG
، يُظهر البحث
البنية التحتية لطيران الإمارات مثل الطرق الملساء و
4  تعد تغطية G نقطة قوة رئيسية ، فهي
رائعة للتسويق ، وأعتقد أن أبو
ظبي على وجه الخصوص تحاول
الابتعاد عن النفط والابتكار
والتكنولوجيا العالية أو نوع من المركبات هو نوع
من الكل في واحد لأنه يتضمن
بطاريات تتضمن رقائق وتتضمن ذكاء اصطناعيًا
ينطوي على كبير  البيانات وأعتقد أن
القدرة على تسليط الضوء على ذلك كجزء من
البنية التحتية لمدينتك أه
حقًا يدفعك إلى المقدمة
ولكن البلد لا يحتل مرتبة عالية جدًا
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالتكنولوجيا المتاحة
وكان هذا هو السوق الذي وضعته حراب جاب
لسقوطنا ، نحن لا نعيد اختراع
العجلة هنا ، لذا فنحن نعرف بالضبط
أين يمكن لأي شخص آخر الوصول إلى هذه
التكنولوجيا نفسها على تلك البرامج شركة
بيانات هي شركة تابعة لـ g42 وهي شركة
مدعومة من قبل صندوق الثروة السيادية لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
وهي شركة التكنولوجيا المدرجة في أبو
ظبي  قالت بورصة الأوراق المالية في
أكتوبر إن الطلب الهائل
والثقة في هذه الأنواع من
حلول الأعمال جعلت الاكتتاب العام ممكنًا ،
وتقول الشركة إنها تأمل في ذلك
تعزيزًا لهدف طيران الإمارات المتمثل في تحسين
الكفاءة والسلامة على الطريق باستخدام
EVS ذاتية القيادة ، أعتقد أننا بحاجة
إلى أن نكون جزءًا من هذا المستقبل الذي نحتاجه
للتأكد من أننا نخفض
انبعاثات الكربون من الشارع نفسه ،
ونرى المزيد من التنقل الذكي بالتأكيد.  هذا
يعني أنه سيكون لدينا الآن
حوادث أقل في هذه المنطقة ، كان أملنا من
قبل الوحدات القادمة في
سباق جائزة أبو ظبي الكبرى حدثًا مهمًا
، حيث بدأت الشركة تجارب الطريق
قبل عام واحد ، حيث تعمل التكنولوجيا
ولكن السائق لا يزال على متنها فقط  في
حال كان ضابط السلامة مطلبًا إلزاميًا
على هؤلاء ، فهذه تقنية جديدة
هم أشخاص ما زالوا يحاولون
توخي الحذر بشأن السماح
للتكنولوجيا بالتحرك بحرية ،
فإننا نضع لوحة التشغيل الخاصة بنا عن قصد
أثناء هذا الحدث لأننا
نحتاجهم لتعظيم البيانات  لفهم
كيفية عملها في منطقة مزدحمة للغاية من
أجل تحسين خدماتنا في
المستقبل